so I've got basically two balances so
I'm pretty much uh
pretty much relying on my family wives
and three kids they are I would say a
very important database for everything
and then when I look at the balance that
I need to bring into the mix between the
role of a CEO of a publicly traded
company which is still small to
beginning of the mid size and growing
and in a competitive environment you
need something that will balance you and
will drive you nuts so that's the role
of sports I would say
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
20-minute leaders is a proud supporter
of Make-a-Wish Israel and Tech to peace
and is in proud collaboration with
secret Court Ventures J Ventures
Riverside Femme Fusion VC Birthright
Excel J impact leap Google for startups
and hippo and in media partnership with
ctek
hello and welcome to an awesome episode
in 20 minute leaders and I'm not just
saying that because I love 20 minute
leaders but because this really is a
great episode that I thoroughly enjoyed
making with yossi carmill the CEO of
celebrite a global leader in digital
intelligence solutions for the public
and private sectors the company's
technology is used in millions of
Investigations around the world helping
thousands of law enforcement agencies to
convict Bad actors and bring Justice to
victims of crime carmill started as one
of celebrate's very first employees and
has been serving as CEO for the past 17
years before joining celebrate he was
Siemens as commercial vice president in
Israel he has more than 25 years of
experience in Management International
sales Business Development and strategic
consultancy prior to working in the
private sector he served at the Israeli
Ministry of Defense
um I'm already so thankful for your time
may let alone that you're today the CEO
of such an amazing company celebrate
your journey spends beyond that and is
definitely not an unconventional from a
from vice president commercial at its
Siemens and then sales at its Telecom
and transitioning to VP sales to CEO
within celebrate and and soon you'll
tell me a little bit about your own
perspective of your own Journey as well
as the the market that celebrate is in
the the different challenges and
opportunities that are presented through
emerging Technologies in your worlds and
so this is going to be an interesting
conversation you'll see and we'll see
where it goes over these 20 short
minutes tell me a little bit about your
journey from your perspective and I want
to start from uh from from you as an
athlete you you wake up at 5 30 a.m
every day which I find fascinating
always tell me a little bit about that
well uh I I indeed I train between six
to seven six to seven days a week
which means practically almost every day
is not every day it's a mix of uh of
running swimming and yoga
uh until seven years ago I'm 56 but when
I when I was wow 49 I'd stopped a row of
few marathons a few triathlons which I
did during my 40s but 40s there since I
was 14
uh through my military track and and
after that Ministry of Defense Sports
was always there and it has to do
something with that first of all it has
to do with I will study two things or
maybe three things which are typically
part of my personality
I would say persistence
High discipline and pretty much well
balanced
if you had the three together
it's out it's somehow you know in our
world or at least in my world I think I
have a fascinating role as the CEO of
celebrity I'm in this world for 69
quarters right now how am I in the
company for in my 19th year uh just on
uh make sure that the mobile doesn't
make any noise but that they need a
balance so I've got basically two
balances I'm pretty much
pretty much relying on my family wife
and three kids they are I would say a
very important database for everything
and then when I look at the balance that
I need to bring into the mix between the
role of a CEO of a publicly traded
company which is still small to
beginning of the mid size and growing
and in a competitive environment you
need something that will balance you and
will drive you nuts so that's the role
of sports I would say
incredible in there we'll leave it to
another to another episode to understand
how you're how you're managing to
balance all of that to maintain such a
such energy and optimism and obviously
that is an aid to all of that
um tell me a little bit about Transit
your personal transitions economics MBA
sales
um leadership to CEO even on a on a on
an abstract level this progression what
was that like for you
anyway I am look I um I I left the house
when I was 18 enjoying um the
paratrooper Unity the Israel in the army
there's a corporation after that uh is
uh as an officer and now I think that
was the first that were the steps when I
gained I would say the real
self-confidence because I was a really
good uh nice disciplined boy
great parents by the way which are still
alive and healthy both of them
and uh I started basically a journey I
would say of well I don't call it
commanding it's a it's a life of
Challengers uh growth within uh I had
the luck that that I would say
qualitative leaders had touched me along
the road and gave me value
and um it's some kind of a leadership
growth uh I would say that um I spent
after the few years working after a few
resumes for the ministry of Defense I
moved to Europe and I left life of 10
years mostly in Germany did my record my
Academy degrees economy and MBA and and
worked in Germany for the first time in
commercialized bush
uh
um and and Siemens uh that that gave me
obviously some kind of an international
and Global Perspective in my life
and uh I I did the German part uh not
only because I found Germany as a great
country
um an amazing country and I had really
um very rich life over there both
private cultural and um and professional
uh at the end of the day I searched for
a relative advantage and they were not
back then there were not so many
Israelis who did the European
arena is part of the professional build
up you could see my news when he's all
doing something in Israel some many
gained a relative to the studied law in
UK or in the USA studied medicine in
Italy back then on I'm talking about the
90s but not that many was riding on that
train of uh learning or making or
started a professional career in Europe
in order to leverage later on and it did
later on I succeeded to do two things to
write on the relative advantage of the
German Israeli
environment to do the Siemens role so
German company in Israel and immediately
after I moved to an Israeli company who
wanted to open the German Market
and then I did also uh my first
managerial roles in the commercial World
VP command search of Siemens and and
after that manage sales and manage sales
teams joining celebrate was something
completely different I joined as
employee number five uh joined a small
company that was amazing in terms of uh
potential and and growth
um and basically over there added the
experience of you know joined as a VP
sales I was uh nominated as a as a CEO
of five four years later on and started
the managerial German a journey we were
acquired by a Japanese public company
later on two years later and I had the
opportunity basically so I was nominated
that cos 2005 2007 acquired by Japanese
public company and I think that was an
amazing experience to do the journey as
a small company which is growing side by
side with a Japanese
shareholdership with a major Market in
the USA really interesting combination
and uh that was um and and celebrate
tukov grew up we I can I don't know uh
what what would you like to hear about
but it's a company that uh dominated the
niche then after that was smart enough
to end another nation grow and Conquer
twice a niche and become a major
marketer and then drop a niche in order
to focus and don't grow from digital
forensics to a digital intelligence
company private to public an amazing
journey
I love it so transformation for the age
of digital investigations let's start
there it's not a trivial statement I can
see why that resonates with a lot of the
the a lot of the potential and growth
that you observed within celebrate as as
a employee number five tell me a little
bit about digital investigations and
then the transformation within this age
foreign
with pleasure so look first of all
we are as a company celebrating we are
serving um
7 000 customers as a B2B out of which
one about five thousand five thousand
plus are in the context of a b2g
business to government a Homeland
Security customers ninety percent of
those five thousand are law enforcement
agencies so celebrate wow these are
professional vendor one of those that
really know how to work with police and
I'm I am I'm I'm encouraged and pretty
much motivated and fascinated by the
world called police forces for several
reasons because the value you bring to
them to the forces is something that
contribute to the personal security of
each one of us of our kids on the
streets of everything I think that what
police is doing is almost holy in terms
of professional and National Security so
first of all the company and myself we
are on that side
those forces are facing today a world of
Investigations which is becoming more
and more digital
and I have to perform under very tough
conditions and I would say that first
and foremost
they are if we are looking at what are
the challenges which are being solved by
the celebrity portfolio those are three
challenges and the challenges are I
would say first
digital evidence quantity and complexity
the second one is the inefficient and
assignable there were in the way that
investigations are being done today and
the third one is um I would say the need
of the police to be ethical and to be
accountable to the way they do
investigations the first one about the
the data um
um
quantity and complexity is the fact that
my customers other police forces today
which are serving each one of us are
facing basically an environment of
explosion of data they are overwhelmed
by data by the quantity of digital
sources you know mobile computer drones
Cloud
routers
cdrs cars videos etc etc
cryptocurrency it's also the amount of
data per device think about the data on
mobile five to six years ago people
compared to the amount of data which a
mobilized they think about the hundreds
of applications and the fact that when
the reason need to deal with those
digital sources and take for example
mobile which is the main expertise
Enterprise think about the encrypted
environment and the locked environment
that they are dealing with so basically
a very complex environment that not only
weigh you and I and other civilians
operating with but also crime a crime
criminals which are becoming more
sophisticated the second priority is the
inefficiency and the The Silo mode look
uh we look at the police TV series we
think that everything over there is very
daunted connected sexy it is not not so
manual work silent work disconnected
between databases and storages and lack
of lack of professional Personnel the
police is very professional but they are
lacking your budget so they are
suffering for backlog inlands in police
station highly amount of mobiles and you
need something that will give an answer
to that and the third
uh the amazing work of police is again
faces the need in the digital era to
give results fast professional to come
to the golden evidence as quick as
possible but on the other hand they need
to pay attention to chain of custody the
rights of the suspect to touch only the
relevant evidence in the context of
targeted investigation so if someone
made a financial crime as a suspect you
do not necessarily need to see the naked
pictures of this baby in the bath which
are saved on the mobile so they need to
be ethical in the way they do
investigation and they need to be
accountable for the evidence and for all
the three challenges one need to bring
an answer and the answer to that
in order to make investigations that
would say smarter faster and more
efficient and bring them as quick as
possible to the golden evidence the
answer to that is among others the
portfolio of celebrates and I will stop
you
unpack
when you're looking at law enforcement
different organizations that are
that are making use of these ethical and
accountable mechanisms
tell me a little bit about the way that
you're structuring these Partnerships
and how do you generate your own
understanding about how to integrate
technology and and celebrates
mechanisms to existing existing
mechanisms right I mean we're talking
about you know some you know you know
long-term strategies different actions
that are being taken by these different
agencies and and you're coming and
you're shifting a little bit you know
augmenting in some senses I'm sure
fixing things in other senses how does
this whole you know in Hebrew mishmash
how does this whole thing take place
I'm not sure I'll give her answer but
it's a discussion actually at the end of
the day so I'll give you my thoughts and
allow me basically to bring it a little
bit down towards
I am
interested by technology by as a person
I'm much more interested by the
the ability of technology to serve the
mode of operation
and I'm fascinated by a business case
that's me all right I will tell you that
uh by the way I could definitely manage
also companies which are not necessarily
technological by Nature however the
question was about
how to combine technology but in in
between slides I would rather take it to
how a simple solution enables a simple
mode of operation and if I go back to
celebrate I think that uh if I can
contribute to a or give a tip to to see
homes in that direction we have the luck
also to be smart listen to customers and
in 2008 to enter into that digital
forensics era or line of business we
were not the first we were made to
strategy and we brought a simple
solution which was by the way designated
to take transform data from a Source
phone to a Target phone in point of sale
of mobile operators that's the original
celebrite we brought that simple
solution simple to use reaching
technology into the police in order to
enable
than to make the challenge of just take
evidence hashed and protected from
mobiles in order to bring golden
evidence as part of Investigation to
bring an actionable evidence that they
can stand behind
celebrate was more than he's the world
champion doing that in Mobile that was
the start
and I reached the situation that in 2014
2015 already
police in the U.S talk all over the
place about the fact that they are
celebrating in rise
in the land
so became I became we became sticky in
the lab of police as much as a
refrigerator in your kitchen or an LCD
in your living room all right and I
would say
I what brought technology in that
simplifies the process give an answer to
a very critical need
in a simple way
and became pretty much a standard but
how
what makes me tutorial successful me too
you're basically penetrate look at your
environment and when you need to be
smart enough in order to create a
technological or any other kind of USB
that creates a gap but the original
entities in that field cannot close and
that's what we succeeded to do that was
the technology but a technology not
necessarily in the technological Edge
because we did it we were the first
company to bring the ability to unlock a
a
um or deal with deleted data and hidden
data on mobile devices we were the first
to bring the Samsung and later on the
iOS and and but what we brought also
something very simple
something simple to use that was that
could used by a simple police officer a
simple examiner and later on also for
those who would like to make a more Deep
dive into reviewer items all of you with
our tools rather more complex or deep
dive
data in order to get a deeper into a
case and for that right away we brought
later on an expansion or an extension of
the portfolio with investigative
analytics AI based machine learning
based giving an answer to the need of
connecting
um or or
surfacing data faster
bringing the ability to narrow millions
of images or or images into the field
which are selected and relevant to the
case connecting between suspects is part
of Link analysis and so on and so forth
and slowly virtually we are adding an
answer so giving answer to the major
pain bringing the ability for the police
to manage the investigations sharing
reviewing a a permission management and
so on and so forth and on the Fly
although we are a software and a product
company we understood that we need also
to give an answer to
enabling the police to stand behind the
evidence also in court so for that we
are building our service Academy so it's
not about only the technology but how do
you support the professional ability of
our customers to stand behind the
evidence all the way not only to extract
it and review it and analyze it but also
to be trained well enough and certified
enough to come and stand behind the
evidence in Grant I'm talking about the
prosecution so what am I telling you is
actually it's how to bring technology
which is suitable to a certain mode of
operation and I my our plan is to update
and upgrade the ability of police with
technology which then enables them to
change the world of operation and this
is why when I look at the company
five to six years ago already when
people say the mobile collection or
review or digital forensic they said
celebrate I would like to see if I'm
viewers from now that I'm contributing
bringing value to the police too by the
way either on the agency level but
sometimes also on a police station 11 or
here or Bureau to digitize the
investigative flow end to end
so they will say who helps me to
digitize it into and they will celebrate
so I'll stop you I hope I gave me some
perceptions here
you didn't just give me some perceptions
but you've opened a whole can of worms
inside of my head with the things that
I'm curious and interested by
um 20 minutes is not nearly enough time
to cover any of the huge items that
you've mentioned but but you're touching
on some very fundamental
um questions about how do you how do you
leverage technology and use the word
simple quite a few times which which I
think speaks a lot to you under your
deep understanding as to at the end how
do you create that stickiness like the
LCD in the living room and the microwave
in the kitchen and how do you then
realize that it's not just enough for
them to to have that stickiness but then
you have to also provide the in-depth so
that they can actually stand behind what
they're doing with this with this
evidence which I think is a is is not a
trivial concept on its own and you'll
see I really want to thank you for for
your time and your energy I learned a
lot in these 20 minutes I I'm gonna take
these 20 minutes and now dive into it
much more myself and I really want to
thank you for being here and uh again
best of luck with the with an amazing
journey with celebrate and everything
else that you're doing and thank you
very much for being here okay thank you
very much for your time and for the
opportunity and good luck yeah thank you
[Music]